thanks jillian all eyes are on the chaos
in afghanistan but border officials say
we cannot forget about the immigration
crisis encounters at our southern border
are at a 21-year high right now joining
us now to react former chief of u.s
border patrol and retired acting ice
director ron vitello good morning to you
sir so the new york post summed up the
current state of affairs this way they
say all eyes are on afghanistan
but the border crisis hasn't gone away
they go on to say leave it to president
joe biden to distract from his
mushrooming border crisis by creating
yet another huge one in afghanistan yet
make no mistake the stampede from the
south towards the mexican border hasn't
slowed it's accelerated so we now have
two crises from one president what's
your reaction
it's terrible that we have to find
ourselves in a situation in 2021 where
the most powerful government on earth
can't protect the people who were
serving for us
and alongside us in afghanistan and we
can't seem to use the policies that were
working to help secure the southern
border and stop a monumental surge that
started back in january and we lived
through all spring and it still
continues today people from all over the
globe if they make it into this
hemisphere they're much
they're likely to become
into the united states whether illegally
and invading the border patrol at the
line or being let in and released
because of these feckless policies that
were instituted in late january this
year yeah you know you bring up the
policy front of this and i wanted to ask
you about that because
president biden said that afghans people
from afghanistan aren't flying directly
um to the united states they're going to
be stopping off at a third country to be
screened first to make sure that they
should be in the u.s and that sounds a
lot like the remain in mexico policy so
why is one of them okay but the other
isn't
well the risks are different but yes
you're right why are we not using the
tools that are available to the us
government to help secure our border and
give border patrol agents and customs
and border protection officers and ice
officials the tools that they had to
prevent a surge like this one why
wouldn't we do that on behalf of the of
the homeland on behalf of homeland
security ask yourself who is who's
benefiting from this policy at the
southern border it's drug cartels they
feed off of this chaos that's more
people that they're being trafficked
that's more drugs that are being
smuggled into the united states that's
more power for them to corrupt
governments and officials at the border
and in the pipeline so who's benefiting
from this it's not the border patrol
agents and their families it's not the
ice agents and their families it's not
border communities and border hospitals
and people who live on that line they're
not benefiting from any of this it's all
misery for them and it's a misery for
many of the people who are in the
pipeline because they're fleeing gangs
they're fleeing violence in their
hometowns they're going to come to some
of the worst neighborhoods in this
country and be preyed upon by those very
gangs that are here in this country yeah
we've seen the gang violence we've we've
seen the drugs pour into our country and
now i think a lot of people are worried
once again about terrorism
how easy would it be for a terrorist to
pay off a
member of the mexican cartel to get them
into the country
you and smugglers have no regard for
where they make their money
and so it's quite possible that a
criminal network a terrorist network
could use the existing pipeline to bring
those who wish to do us harm through
that we worked on that the entire time
that's why the department was created to
prevent that from happening that's why
the border patrol was beefed up under
prior administrations so we could have
operational control of the border so if
somebody was in that pipeline we could
find them and so yes we have to be
concerned about that but the risks are
real and these criminal cartels
terrorist organizations are going to
feed off of this chaos yeah border
patrol agents they work on behalf of our
national security and many of them say
that they just can't do their jobs
anymore ron vitello thank you so much
for joining us thanks for waking up
early appreciate it thank you all right